auftritt sibylle berg
für das interview treffen wir uns mit
der schriftstellerin an einem besonderen
ort in diesem atelier haus könnte ihr
neuer roman spielen
sibylle bergs texte sind immer frech
dreckig erbarmungslos nüchtern
doch im neuen buch ist es anders es geht
um die liebe und damit ist oft ziemlich
schwierig ich glaube am anfang ist es
gar nicht kompliziert ist wird einfach
im laufe der zeit kompliziert werden
eben verliebtheit sich zu aller liebe
wandelt oder mal dass das glück hat dass
das passiert und irgendwie das
hormonellen bahn wirklich für eine tiefe
freundschaft wird sie hat gespür für
inszenierungen für ihren neuen roman der
tag als meine frau einen mann fand
produzierte sie einen buchtrailer in der
weiblichen hauptrolle
sibylle berg es geht um chloé und rasmus
seit rund zehn jahren ein paar ihre
beziehung verlässlich gleichberechtigt
erwachsen und bequem geworden
irgendwann weiß natürlich wie deine
partnerin oder dem partner funktioniert
und möchtest dich also im guten fall des
dass er oder sie sich wohlfühlt und dann
liegst du auch manchmal ein bisschen
okay du bist großartig du musst es ganz
fantastisch sex ist für beide so meinen
sie unwichtig reine routine
ich bin morgens nicht sexuell doch seit
jahren küsst mich rasmus ohne zu
bemerken dass ich mich abmelde
die augen verdrehen oder meine zunge aus
dem mund hängen lasse als sei ich
verendet rasmus höchst in den
gemeinsamen ferien beginnt chloe eine
affäre mit dem masseur ihre lust erwacht
zu neuem leben
es sind die berührungen von dem ich die
letzten 20 jahre geträumt habe
weil sie mehr waren als hände auf mir
weil sie hungrig machten und wahnsinnig
ich klappt die verknallt sich wirklich
das ist wirklich das was verlieben ist
hormone wahnsinn anfassen wollen
auspacken wollen anfassen wollen
ablenken wollen
da geht es nicht um irgendwie finden wir
bei schlingensief großartig verliebtheit
ist reine körper chemie meint berg doch
diese erkenntnis nutzt ihren figuren
wenig rasmus leidet oder chloé affäre
und chloe
so
tschüss
chloe denkt nur an sex mit dem masseur
den sie zu hause einquartiert hat obwohl
keiner der drei der körperlichen
anziehungskraft wirklich traut stecken
sie fest
sibylle bergs roman ist eine
versuchsanordnung was passiert mit einem
paar wenn sich einer von beiden fremd
verliebt was ist mit dem der übrig
bleibt
es gibt ja so plattitüden wie aber das
sind immer beide daran schuld sind sie
nicht das ist einfach eine partei hat
daneben den wunsch ich möchte dem
nachgehen und ich möchte noch mal wissen
wie das ist mit mit aufregungen und was
neues
natürlich kann man das auf sechs
reduzieren weil sechste die triebfeder
von allen ist
ich glaube es ist nur eine metapher für
wirklich dieses noch einmal richtig wild
sein und von sinnen seien explizit und
kritisch untersucht berg begierde
doch auch der wahren liebe begegnet sie
mit skepsis und sarkasmus
nichts langweiligeres das feuer wurden
ihre analyse ist haarscharf doch sie
blickt auch überraschend warmherzig auf
diese seltsame spezies mensch so dass du
uns zu rechnen war bist und wirklich
auch vergisst was hast du zu hause und
wofür ja wofür haben wir eigentlich
gelebt oder dass vielleicht ja auch der
verrat den du an dieser freundschaft die
du mit deinem partner seiner partnerin
hast ist das völlig egal ist wenn du die
nicht dagegen ankommst diese
verliebtheit das merkst du sehr schnell
und es ist das kann jetzt das kann jetzt
was geben oder anderen ist die frage
gehst du demnach oder gäste dem aus dem
weg das ist eigentlich die entscheidung
litz da die romantikerin durch liebe
frau war auf jeden fall bietet uns ihr
roman reibungsfläche und ihr schreibstil
ist wie immer umwerfend eigen